salut si vous suivez la chaîne ou si
vous avez vu cette vidéo n'êtes pas sans
savoir que j'ai deux trophées youtube un
que j'ai eu légalement il ya un autre
que que j'ai eu moins légales mais le
fait est que ce sont deux trophées
originaux et qu'aujourd'hui je vous
donne l'occasion d'en gagner 1 des 2 mai
pour ça va falloir faire chauffer vos
neurones alors génériques
[Musique]
restez bien jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo
je vais vous donner des informations
importantes pour gagner le trophée et de
rendez vous pour essayer de gagner le
trophée que je vous l'envoie ou qu'on se
rencontre
j'ai créé une énigme depuis plusieurs
semaines vous pouviez déjà essayé de
résoudre quelques indices jeu maintenant
lancer une vidéo de 30 secondes
cette vidéo de 30 secondes c'est
l'énigme c'est l'énigme finale pour
recevoir le trophée ecoutez-la bien
détaillé la bien et on se retrouve juste
après pour quelques informations
supplémentaires vous êtes prêts alors
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'était un petit peu rapide peut-être je
vous conseille quand même de la regarder
soit en solo soit de revenir en arrière
en tout cas prenez le temps de la la
déplier de la députée même elle même
fait référence à trois vidéos qui sont
déjà passés sur la chaîne et dans la
finalité de cette énigme vous allez vous
retrouver face à di lire dans ces 10
lien il ya un formulaire la fin de
l'énigme c'est de répondre à ce
formulaire mais si vous répondez à deux
formulaires différent et ça le sera avec
le nom le prénom ou le mail ou le code
postale ou l'adresse ip alors vous êtes
automatiquement disqualifiés vous ne
devez et ne pouvait répondre qu'à un
seul formulaire c'est une condition
sinequanone c'est à dire que quand vous
répondez c'est vous êtes sûrs d'être au
bon endroit
comment on va savoir qui a gagné bien
c'est très simple je vais prendre les
100 premiers à avoir répondu juste et
parmi ces personnes qui ont réussi je
prendrai quelqu'un au sort ça veut dire
que la rapidité rentrent en ligne de
compte
il faut absolument faire partie des 100
premiers à trouver mais là où vous avez
de la chance même si la rapidité
rentrent en compte
tu ne sais pas si simple à trouver je
suis même pas sûr qu'il s'en personnes
qui vont trouver je sais pas vous pouvez
aussi vous organisé à plusieurs
d'ailleurs bref je dirais donc une
personne ne sort et geoffrey une vidéo
je vous expliquerai toutes les réponses
de toute l'énigme général et des
souhaits nîmes et de tous les indices et
en même temps j'annoncerai pour la
première fois je le ferai pas avant le
nom du gagnant ou de la gagnante
donc le seul manière de savoir qu'on a
gagné ou pas ce sera de regarder la
vidéo réponse je vous donne également de
rendez vous avant qu'on se quitte
le premier rendez vous c'est le 2 mai à
18h pour un faq live mais à destination
principalement des créateurs et des
vidéastes ça existe aux états unis
depuis pas mal de temps et youtube a
décidé de le faire pour la première fois
en france et j'ai l'honneur d'être le
premier acte est donc si vous êtes
créateur si vous êtes vidéastes ou si
vous voulez simplement participer à ça
je vous mets un lien dans la description
ce sera donc en live en streaming ce qui
m'amène au deuxième rendez vous je vais
refaire un live un petit peu comme on a
fait l'autre jour sur la chaîne si vous
n'avez pas vu j'ai mis la vidéo là
quelque part on a joué ensemble un jeu
d'énigmes et c'était vraiment interactif
et très participatif durant un petit peu
moins d'une heure j'ai adoré ça je crois
par un manque ça vous a plu aussi donc
je vais en remettra en place je
l'annoncerai sur twitter sur installer
sur facebook n'hésitez pas à me rajouter
vous avez les liens dans la description
je crois que j'ai tout dit maintenant il
va falloir chercher quelle est la
réponse à cette énigme et je vous donne
rendez vous très bientôt
ciao
m